David, if Donald Trump is unfortunately reelected
in November of 2020, how bad do you think
his second term would be?
So in thinking about a Trump second term,
there are two sides to it.
One is Trump is incredibly childish and vindictive.
The other side is Trump is incredibly lazy.
So I would predict that a second term Trump
would simultaneously be more unhinged and
brazen and authoritarian in going after his
political enemies, using executive orders
to do whatever he wants more frequently.
But at the same time, I see him watching a
lot more TV and playing a lot more golf and
being even lazier than he has been because
he's not gonna have anything else to campaign
for.
Maybe towards the end of his second term,
Trump would have a Republican nominee to campaign
for if they believe that it would be useful.
Remember back in two thousand eight, you didn't
see George W. Bush campaigning for John McCain
very much because George W. Bush's approval
rating was in the toilet.
And it wouldn't have been a good thing for
McCain to have Bush out there prominently.
So I would expect a few different things.
Trump's not going to have his rallies, so
he'll watch more TV and play more golf.
He'll feed his ego on Twitter.
In terms of what he will get done, certainly
Donald Trump will continue to get a lot done
on judges because Trump is just a tool in
Mitch McConnell's toolbox, so to speak, when
it comes to judges.
And they will continue.
They may get more Supreme Court justices on
the court, depending on who goes and who stays
in Trump's second term.
They will keep putting more federal judges
in.
And so no doubt, if Trump is given four more
years, laziness aside, tweeting aside, his
effect on the Jewish judiciary is going to
be absolutely damaging for decades to come.
That's going to continue.
Beyond that, I don't believe you will see
Trump do much of significance when it comes
to big policy achievements.
I don't think Trump will get anything done
on health care the way he promised to do during
his first term.
And a lot of the reason is Trump doesn't really
believe in what he's doing.
You know, Trump put together this faux conservative
ideology where he pretended to care about
debt and he pretended to care about, you know,
stopping abortion and stuff.
He didn't care about his entire life.
And Trump's ideology is not a conservative
ideology.
It's what I call.
And so a sort of imbecilic reactionary ideology
where Trump just is very opinionated.
And in some cases he is very reactionary in
other cases.
He's libertarian in the sense that he doesn't
care what people do.
He's taking positions on some of these issues
because he's figured out that it appeals to
evangelical and other right wing voters.
So because Donald Trump doesn't really have
a very important or significant political
ideology as such, I think Trump will not get
much done at all.
And he's just going to kind of hang out now.
His authoritarianism, combined with his vindictive
nature to me, suggest that in addition to
helping Mitch McConnell get his judges in,
maybe trying to get some kind of tax cuts
done and putting continuing to tweet and watch
TV, there is a very good chance that Donald
Trump is going to really start taking his
anger out even more on media people that he
doesn't like, on politicians that he feels
haven't been supportive enough of him.
So I would expect a second term Trump will
really try to ruin people's lives, his enemies
lives, the people that he perceives as his
damaged enemies or not having been with him
while he mostly just rubber stamps, whatever
Republicans convinced him to do, it will be
very, very ugly.
It will be very ugly.
And it is of of course not.
I don't want to say renewed importance because
it's been of constant importance that we do
everything we can to remove this guy in November.
Please don't forget that Monday, Memorial
Day, we have a one day David Pakman show membership
explosion planned.
It's been months since we did any of these
big membership specials Monday.
Everybody on our mailing list will get an
email.
The email will say a lot of good things about
you.
It will say you're a beautiful person.
You're a tremendous, tremendously good person
for being on our mailing list and watching
the show.
Listen.
We'll sing your praises, but then here's the
key part.
The e-mail that goes out on Memorial Day will
tell you how to get a disgustingly I mean,
this is a vilely huete is Father Edward.
It's a vile, huge discount off of membership
and it'll be a one day special.
OK, get on the mailing list at David Pakman
dot com top right of the Web site.
You type in your e-mail address.
You'll be on the mailing list.
Monday, you'll get an e-mail with this membership
special.
And you will also, as a member, get access
who'd be bonus show, which today is hosted
by producer Pat.
He will talk to you on the bonus show momentarily.
I will be back with you in.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.